[Musique]
il y a deux ans le parlement anglais a
été victime d'une cyber attaques des
hackers ont testé des milliers de mots
de passe et on finit par compromettre
quelques comptes
il ya 20 ans mes parents ont protégé la
télévision avec un code mon frère et moi
les avons tous testés 00 00 non
00 01 non plus etc
jusqu'à ce que 1 6 6 3 magie la télé
s'est allumé alors évidemment les enjeux
sont pas les mêmes mais la technique est
similaire
nous vivons aujourd'hui un changement
majeur dans l'histoire de l'humanité
après les révolutions cognitives
agricoles industrielles nous vivons
aujourd'hui ce que certains appellent
une révolution numérique
nous avons accès à internet partout tout
le temps avec notre ordinateur
notre smartphone nos voitures voire même
notre brosse à dents mais à quel prix
cette ouverture sur le monde
elle est accessible à tout le monde
indépendamment de l'âge ou de la langue
elle est facile pratique intuitive
à tel point que si on demandait aux plus
jeunes d'entre nous comment il ferait
pour vivre sans internet
la plupart ne serait pas répondre mais
cette simplicité cache une invisible
complexité c'est un peu comme une
voiture
tout le monde peut apprendre à conduire
en quelques heures ou quelques dizaines
d'heures mais presque personne ne
comprend réellement le fonctionnement
d'un moteur ou me direz oui c'est normal
c'est parce qu'on en a pas besoin
et vous auriez raison maintenant il
existe des voitures qui détecte
automatiquement des panneaux de stop ou
des feux tricolores
imaginez alors un instant que je m'amuse
à coller un autocollant en forme de
panneau stop à l'arrière de ma voiture
est bien une voiture autonome pourrait
penser que c'est un vrai panneaux épiler
net
je vous laisse imaginer les dégâts que
cela pourrait avoir sur l'autoroute
pourquoi je vous donne cet exemple c'est
pour montrer que ce qui paraît simple
doit en réalité gérer un nombre énorme
de cas pour s'adapter à toutes les
situations
et comme derrière tout ça ce sont des
humains qui réfléchissent il arrive
qu'il ne pense pas à toutes les
situations
le hacker dans tout ça c'est celui qui
s'intéresse à city à ces situations
nous allons donc voir ensemble ce qu'un
hacker peut faire à votre insu et les
quelques réflexes que vous pouvez
adopter pour vous en protéger
la question principale que se pose un
hacker et qu'est-ce qu'il se passe si il
me demande ma date de naissance
qu'est ce qui se passe si je mets mon
prénom à la place on me demande de
mettre une photo de profil
qu'est ce qui se passe si je mets un
document word à la place bien parfois
une erreur simple mais t'es bête ou quoi
je t'ai demandé une date de naissance
mais parfois des comportements
inattendus
bonjour romain joyeux anniversaire vous
avez 4,36 millions d'années un autre
exemple de cas limites
vous connaissez probablement les bornes
chez mcdonald's sur lesquels on peut
passer des commandes est bien un hacker
s'est intéressée à ces bornes
il a trouvé quelque chose d'intéressant
l'idée c'est qu'un burger sur ces bornes
coûte un dollar sauf que s'il demandait
de retirer le burger le la viande de son
burger mcdonald's devait lui rembourser
1 dollar et 10 centimes
donc 10 centimes de plus que le prix du
burger il a donc répété cette opération
de 10 fois acheté 10 burger retirer la
viande elle s'est retrouvée avec 10 x 10
centimes un dollar avec ce nouveau
dollars il s'est acheté un burger
cette fois-ci gratuitement donc résultat
des courses dit burger sans viande
un burger complet mais tout ça
gratuitement eh bien ces cas limites
les hackers les tests dans tout ce qu'on
utilise le quotidien et à force de
tester il trouve des choses
intéressantes
vous êtes peut-être déjà arrivé à un
aéroport un peu en avance et vous avez
voulu passer le temps et là vous avez vu
fruits airport ou eye-fi vous vous y
êtes connecté
vous êtes allez sur youtube y avait
passé le temps avec quelques vidéos de
chatons comme c'est remarquable mais
est-ce que vous êtes déjà demandé c'est
quoi un wifi enfin concrètement ces
coins wifi et bien moi je vais vous
répondre
le wifi ce sont des ondes et les ondes
sa part dans toutes les directions
imaginez la scène suivante vous êtes au
bord d'un lac
il ya une brume épaisse qu'on ne voit
pas cinq mètres et vous voulez prévenir
votre ami qui se retrouve de l'autre
côté du lac que vous venez d'arriver
vous pourriez crier mais ce ne serait
pas très discret à la place vous décidé
de jeter un caillou dans l'eau une onde
se propage alors silencieusement et
finit par atteindre votre ami il fait
que vous êtes arrivé c'est parfait
maintenant il peut y avoir quelqu'un
d'autre aux abords du lac
et comme londres se propage dans toutes
les directions
sept autres personnes sera également
vous êtes arrivé elle peut même à son
tour jeté un caillou dans l'eau londres
va vous parvenir et vous penserez que
c'est votre ami qui vous répond eh bien
le wifi dans l'aéroport c'est un peu le
même principe
lorsque vous voyez free airport way
faille
c'est en fait un équipement de
l'aéroport qui envoie une onde dans
toutes les directions
indiquant je suis fier pour trois
failles vous vous y connecter et tout
votre comme toutes vos communications
passent par lui mais comme dans
l'histoire du lac
une autre personne peut être dans
l'aéroport et indiqué je suis pris à
bord du wild eyes en envoyant des ondes
dans toutes les directions
sauf que ça pour vous c'est invisible
vous ne remarquez pas vous vous
connectez à ce wifi et toutes vos
communications passent par l'équipement
du hacker il existe tout un tas d'autres
exemples de technologie qu'on utilise au
quotidien et que l' axe que les hackers
exploitent en explorant l'invisible en
tant qu'utilisateur et acteurs de la
révolution numérique
vous vous devez de limiter les risques
pour vous en protéger
s'il faut retenir une chose danse
histoire c'est que si quelque chose vous
paraît pratique simple il faut que vous
réfléchissiez aux données que ça utilise
car à coeur pourra potentiellement y
accéder alors pour ça trois rêves trois
réflexes simples le premier si vous
accédez à internet dans un endroit
public
évitez d'accéder à des données
personnelles ou sensibles dont youtube
avec les vidéos de chatons
ok mais votre compte en banque évitez le
deuxième réflexe si que si vous voulez
acheter des objets connectés
évitez également ceux qui ont accès à
des données sensibles donc une lampe
connectés qui accès à votre lumière
ok mais un babyphone qui a accès au son
et à l'image de votre enfant non et
enfin troisième réflexe si vous n'êtes
pas connecté
éteignez votre wifi éteignez votre
bluetooth en plus ça vous fera
économiser un petit peu de batterie
alors bien entendu certains de ces
conseils tombe sous le sens dans
certaines situations il suffit de voir
les débats animés autour des voitures
autonomes à qui on confie notre vie
données relativement sensible mais ce
n'est pas toujours c'est évident comme
on a pu le voir avec le wifi dont
finalement la fluidité la simplicité
oui mais à quel dépens c'est à vous d'en
décider
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]